all right daniel
where you from where'd you grow up
eastern kentucky
and tell me about uh
your parents growing up yeah mom and dad
yeah yeah i had both parents
and i was blessed with great parents
they're both still alive and still
together they
have always been there for me
how would you describe your childhood in
general
oh good i had a good happy childhood i'm
uh
there's three brothers uh you know
there's three
my mom had three sons
three of us i'm the middle one and uh
yeah
you know there's that whole middle child
thing i guess i guess i'm the black
sheep of the family
but uh yeah for the most part it was a
good childhood happy you know that's
great
what kind of made you the black sheep
i don't know i don't know what it was it
uh
i think it could have been early on you
know in in school uh
i i don't know i i traced it all the way
back to elementary school where i went
it was kind of a
rough school and you know uh
seems like my issues kind of started
there back in fourth grade i guess
you know
but your story
is similar to a lot of people from this
part of the country it is definitely
yeah
yeah all the way i mean
you know uh
nothing really chaotic happened or
anything you know around it was uh
pretty normal for the most part um i
graduated high school in 98 and uh
i think in 1995 oxycontin
came on the market
and
it seemed like maybe 96-97 it hit here
and that's when everything changed here
it was um
uh it was nuts really i mean ridiculous
you saw this region probably harder than
anywhere in the country yeah it seemed
to you know it uh
i don't know what it was about that
really if it was the uh
you know the work people did here they
got hurt more more susceptible to
you know injuries or whatnot but it
didn't really matter what injury you had
it seemed like you could sprain your
ankle and go to the doctor and get
oxycontin you know so what you started
to see was
you know people that
were great people you grew up with
you've known them all your life you know
good families
you know you would hear about someone
you know that
vaguely you know something about them
and and oxycontin and then you'd see
them a year later and their life was
just completely different you know
that was a common thing and uh
i don't know it uh
progressively just gotten worse and then
in turn i guess what you're led with was
those same people became dealers to to
support their habit you know and uh
i don't know it
it was new to everybody and it was just
a
plague of
darkness really you know
one percentage of people from your
generation you think got
involved
i would say
maybe six out of ten you know something
like that
maybe
maybe more you know
and you
because all that was so new to everybody
you had you know a lot of judgment i i
remember myself you know
i would see someone that
you know uh
become an addict and i would i'd be like
you know i'd never do that you know
that's not going to be me you know
um
i'll just stick to my beer and you know
that's i can't become an addict you know
and
i don't know i still feel guilty about
that you know the judgment and
but uh i wasn't the only one i mean a
lot of people said that and
but
it doesn't discriminate you know
later on i guess
it would have been i was going to a
community college and i was at a party
one night and uh
i made a
an error in judgment i jumped off of an
inside balcony at this house party
and uh i broke my
right leg really bad uh three places uh
i've had
six surgeries
uh on that leg and that led to
kind of my downward spiral you know
at first after the surgeries i was fine
i didn't
you know there was no type of drug abuse
at all
um
but when it got to where i had to
to go back to work and make money i
framed houses for a living
and
i had to get back to work you know to
support myself and
that's when i had to
you know to have more medicine and then
eventually you know
i was in full blown addiction you know i
was in
pain management for 18 years
and
that was the start of all
all my issues with it you know
yeah it was 18 years of you know
bouncing around to different doctors you
know
and everybody knows i guess that
addiction's a
you know a progressive disease it just
gets worse and
[Music]
it progressively gotten worse you know
got worse for me you know and uh
it was a long rough road
for sure
uh 20 years i had a 20-year run of chaos
and basically
um
what was your drug mainly
it was
yeah the oxycotin
opana of methadone
and then later on heroin and some
fentanyl
which fentanyl now is really bad around
here and uh
meth too but i
strangely enough i think
a lot of the meth abuse can be traced
back to the
the oxycotin issue too you know
all kinds of people i know that are now
meth addicts they
they used to be opiate addicts and they
they tried to get clean and they
felt so bad you know they were sick all
the time
that's something a lot of people don't
understand it's just how bad the
sickness can be you know you're when you
come off a real strong opiate whether
whatever it is heroin
opana or whatever you're you know you
just can't get up and live a productive
life you know
and a lot of those people
would turn to meth and
you know they would be superman for a
while you know
have energy they could get up and go go
back to work whatever you know after
years of not doing anything you know
but uh
then you see them six months later and
they're
you know they're in full-blown meth
addiction you know which
you know depending on who you ask may
even be worse you know
so what what kind of
behavior what kind of trouble did you
get into when you were
in your uh in your addiction
you know luckily
i don't know how to explain this really
i
uh
through all my addiction i don't know if
it was because of my childhood uh
i tried to hold on to my
my values you know i had a strong moral
compass through it all i didn't steal
anything
uh
i tried to always
hustle and work for whatever i had to
get uh
yeah that doesn't make me better than
anybody i'm just you know uh it allowed
me to not
get hemmed up in any real bad trouble
you know i've only been to jail a couple
of times uh
i've about died a few times i've
overdosed twice
i
had a guy
nearly blow my head off once with a
pistol
um
i
went to a place to and i was really bad
sick and uh
crashing out and uh
i went to a place to
to get some
so i think it was opana
and uh
the person i dealt with i thought they
were home they were supposed to be home
the front door of this little house was
wide open
and
i come up on the porch and i yell for
the person basically just to announce
myself
and i hear someone inside mumbling you
know kind of
incoherently you know you i don't even
really know what they were saying
and uh so i stepped around into the
front of the door
and i
i say
i'd start just to ask for the person i'm
there to see
it didn't get that far i
heard him briefly say something about
the neighbors
and the guy was
sitting at a tray
in front of a recliner and he was
bagging meth up
and uh
he pulled out a nine millimeter and
pulled up and leveled it right at my
head and shot out through the doorway
and uh
it was
that was the closest i've ever came to
the straight just instantly dying you
know
i did have a gun to my head another time
but
you know that was
by me i was gonna take my own life at a
different time
but
you know uh
the experiences were very different
you know
yeah the uh
yeah he leveled leveled the gun up shot
and i was about
eight feet maybe ten feet from him in
the doorway
and just
by the grace of whatever luckily he
missed me to the right
and i could feel the energy of the the
muzzle blast you know like my cheeks
wrinkled like the percussion of the
of the shot uh
you know a shock wave travels aways from
a muzzle you know and uh i guess i felt
the end of that by my head
um but
yeah it shook me up a little bit you
know
uh yeah i wasn't high at the time or
anything i was sick and so i was
thinking pretty queer you know
that messed with me for a while
you've had trouble with the police too
it sounds like
yeah yeah some uh it's a small town you
know you
uh
classism's a real thing here and
you know
unfortunately once you
deal with addiction you know you're
going to be marked or labeled as an
addict you know a lot of judgment goes
with that once they know
in any way that you're
associated with it and then
this is such a small place you know
every time you move they're gonna know
who you are
but so i mean there's a lot
a lot of corruption that comes with that
too you know yeah like for example i uh
and i went to another place one time to
you know to get get some stuff
uh
i think this time it was it was opana
too i'd been in bed all day sick you
know
deathly sick
and uh
the place i went to
uh
kind of next door there was a woman that
was really jealous i i knew her son
really well
she knew me and uh
she had gotten word that i was coming to
this place to get something
and i always had a bad feeling about her
you know like an uneasy feeling like you
don't know what she's capable of you
know she may
you know she may knock me out or
something you know and uh but i
so i went to this place that night to
get some stuff
and got it and and i i could tell that
she wasn't anywhere around her place or
i thought so you know so i left and was
driving back out it was about 20 minutes
from my house here you don't just walk
next door and get something you kind of
gotta
meet someone or drive for it and uh
so i was driving back out this country
road and uh
and i met a car and
like i said i'd been sick all day i was
fine to drive good to go and i meet this
car and and they they
shine a spotlight into my windshield and
they spin around light me up and get
behind me
and uh
it's a local deputy you know
i knew him but uh he let on like he
didn't recognize me at first
and he tells me to get out and he asks
where i've been you know
and uh
so i told him i'd been on a different
ridge a different road and that i was
bringing a friend of mine some propane
it was in the winter time
and uh
he said well i got a call that there was
some drug activity going on
over at this other this other ridge kind
of next to it and
i said well i can't help what call you
god it wasn't me you know
but he asked me to get out and uh
when he lit me up with his lights i
i put
the pills i had in the baggie i put them
down in my waistband
kind of right above my my junk you know
and uh
i didn't put them way down in there i
didn't want them to fall out because i
knew you know what was going on
and uh i thought i'd be good to go you
know well he
he gave me a field sobriety test
everything was good to go i passed it
uh
and he said well
he said there's something going on with
your eyes you know he said that's an
indicator that you're you're under the
influence
and
so naturally i s you know i said no man
i've been sick all day i'm good to go
i'm not under any influence
and he said
he said you know i hate to do this he
said
he said i really hate to have to deal
with this tonight
and at first he said that the first time
i didn't think much of it you know i
just thought well
he's just acting like that
and uh
then i realized and heard other stories
about him later he was
leaving me an opening to pay him off you
know to uh
to bribe him i guess you know if i'd had
a
50 bucks to drop on the ground or
something i'm sure i would have
got out of all of it you know
but
he kept saying you know i really hate to
do this you know i don't have to do this
to you
and
so after the
sobriety ted the field sobriety test he
he patted me down and he put his thumb
down my waistband
and
ran his thumb around the top of my
yarn below my belt and he found what i
had so
that's just an example of what goes on
daily here you know
had i have not had that on me i
still would have went to jail with just
a dui and but because he found that i
you know i
led to a possession charge and a dui but
it's
just
i don't know i've heard that about other
small towns how bad it can be
if if someone knows like for example
suboxone is a part of my recovery
uh
and
for example if of a
deputy and you're in this
county or other counties like it know
that you're
prescribed suboxone you know they'll
stop you
and and they'll give you a dui for
for having
suboxone but even though it's you're
illegal to drive on it you know
uh they still want to put you through
the court docket you know keep all that
full and going good you know
and uh
it just it just happens all the time
here you know
you can try to you can yeah i could have
gotten my blood drawn and
chose to
you know go that route and maybe fight
it but
uh
it's just an example of how it can be
here you know
so law enforcement is
is part of the problem yeah
and it's you know
there's a history of that too it goes
all the way back to
i'm sure before but you know the late
90s with when when oxycontin became a
thing uh
you know i can remember the start of it
way back then but uh
yeah it's it's always been an issue
you know
you know you live in the life
of addiction and heavy drug use in a
small town like this you you get to know
everybody
see things and hear things that
uh
you you know you start to see just how
bad it is uh
and
you know it may start with a deputy or a
you know a volunteer
you know but
in some cases
it definitely goes as high up as the
sheriff you know
all the way to the top and and has for a
long time and
not just here you know
you know other company excuse me other
counties around uh
in other counties it's been a bad issue
as well you know
there was a
really big
uh deal with one in a neighboring county
that a journalist was actually able to
take a sheriff down there for basically
doing the same thing
it was a little different in his case he
was using drugs a lot more but in
selling guns and that he confiscated
but uh he was definitely involved in
bribery as well you know but
uh
i imagine any little small town it could
be the same way but it's definitely this
pretty bad here
so so you've gotten clean yeah
yeah
uh almost four years yeah
yeah i uh
i i've tried other times i mean anybody
that's been
addicted for 20 years i mean you're
going to have other i've been to rehab
some you know
several times
but
i just got completely exhausted with it
the darkness and
you know it's hard on your on your soul
to live this way and uh
i
found a doctor that actually cared about
me and started taking suboxone and
that's a part of my recovery i don't
care to tell anyone but
uh
i uh
it has a bad rap i mean people you know
they they say things about it like it's
an opiate or it's just trading one drug
for another but
it's not it it may
work on the same receptors in your brain
but it's not an opiate i mean it doesn't
make you high you're not gonna you can't
physically can't overdose on it or
anything like that
but uh
yeah i was able to get in a good
suboxone program with a
a good doctor that that actually cares
about people they're not just running to
you know to make money you know
this bunch actually
cared and would would work with me and
wanted to help me
um that makes all the difference you're
still using suboxone yeah some uh i've
tapered down quite a bit but it is still
part of my recovery
how is recovery today for you
compared to like before you ever started
using
it's uh well i'm not gonna lie it's not
all
all great uh
i mean it's good i mean i'm
blessed to be still be alive and and you
know
luckily i i guess i was
i've always been i had the tolerance of
a rhino you know i'm kind of
uh i think if it weren't for that i
would be dead by now you know the amount
of drugs i was doing but
uh
yeah
it's it's harder than i thought it'd be
it's uh
i guess after 20 years of living that
way you know it
the mental part of it's what i
i still have an issue with you know
being able to cope with things and uh
um
i had an old guy tell me one time that
uh
he he's been queen 20 years or something
and uh
he told me he's like
he's like the only way i can stay clean
and be
remotely happy is to do something good
for somebody every day
and he said not the kind of good that
you're going to talk about or what you
know
uh not the kind of good you're going to
do in front of somebody i'm talking
about the kind of good that
it might be little [ __ ] it may be
something big but just something only
you know about and the person you're
doing it for
you know you got to give back and uh
he said he said that's the only way i
can i could ever do it and be happy you
know
and so i i started doing that and that's
helped a lot you know
but
yeah i don't know i think i just need to
be honest with you i need more
i just need to work on the the mental
part of it more you know is the urge
still there to use uh yeah yeah you know
i mean that's i imagine it's always
going to be it uh
um
i have dreams you know i don't know if
you know what a drug dream is but you
know you
you'll have a
a blissful dream that you're you know
that you're using and
you'll wake up and obviously you're not
using but i mean that happens all the
time uh
and i think a lot of it
it could be with with me is the you know
i deal with a lot of chronic pain i've
uh
kind of banged up you know
i've got a bad back neck and uh so i
deal with the pain and i i think that
leads to a lot more cravings but yeah i
imagine i'm going to crave it until i
die you know
what do you think the reason this region
is so
like so many people are
involved in drugs
i think it's poverty
you know this is the
second poorest uh you know well i don't
want to say that
it's one of the poorest parts of the
country yeah it's definitely one of the
poorest parts of the country but uh
poverty definitely
and
i think that's the main reason uh
and you know you
as you've seen there's not a lot to do
around here there's nothing to do around
here you know unless you're into the
outdoors
and uh
this area doesn't seem i mean if on from
the outside looking in it doesn't seem
um
to be one of the poorest places in the
world but it's one of the most
it's because it's surrounded by
so much sheer beauty that it kind of
kind of puts a band-aid on it you know
uh
but yeah it's definitely
got a lot to do with poverty and
it's just a weird place i mean
for example cancer the cancer rates are
astronomical here compared to other
places you know
i think that's got to do with poverty
too and depression you know
i don't want to sound like everybody's
down and out and sad you know but
there is definitely a lot of depression
around here you know and coal mining is
kind of
dried up and yeah it's dried up the uh
that was the biggest source of income
yeah yeah that and logging too and uh
so much of this area is public land so
there's not
you know you can't uh
really use those resources you know like
you can in other places uh
so short of a couple factories i mean
it's just little convenience stores and
there's not even a walmart around you
know so
it's
yeah it's definitely a poor area
and
you know the
the beauty kind of masks
just how bad the drug problem is too you
know uh
per capita i would say that this
this area is as bad as anywhere in the
world you know it just doesn't seem like
it because there's not as many people
you know
and i'm glad i would be chaotic if there
were but
um
yeah it's a unique place you know and uh
there's some unique problems going on
with it that
hopefully one day will be better you
know
one decision can snowball into
a lifetime of
you know
darkness and failure if you're not
careful you know
um but i mean i'm doing better now i've
uh
you know bass fishing tournament fishing
was a big
dream of mine you know when i was coming
up and
uh
that's all i ever wanted to do you know
and uh
luckily i'm i'm getting back into that
now i'm
moving on you know i've got a great wife
i think
i've had a great support system that a
lot of people don't have you know and uh
it can
mean everything you know
and i'm definitely lucky you know
i know how full well how bad it could be
you know
i mean straight up
if i didn't have the people
around me that i have around me you know
i know there's no way i'd still be
around you know
you you go through this for 20 years
the trauma and fallout from it you know
what it what it does to you mentally you
know
your self-esteem things like that
uh
you gotta have good people around you
to be successful you know it's
very damn hard to do it by yourself you
know i guess it may be possible but
without the people around me you know i
don't know i don't i think i'd be dead
for sure
or in prison you know
i was definitely blessed with a
a great support system you know i've got
a wonderful wife
we've been together 11 years she's been
through
a lot of [ __ ] you know
crazy [ __ ] she should never have to have
dealt with
um
and my mom and dad you know both of them
they've been great
and
i focus on on that
and
i think that's what
has kept me from you know they say not
to you know you can't recover for
anybody else you got to do it for you
and i do you know but
you know i'll spend the rest of my life
making
you know making things up to them that
that i put them through you know
i'll gladly do it though you know
but uh you know
it's a
you know you do this for 20 years you're
going to have a lot of regret
in your heart from it
just the you know the amount of guilt
and everything and
if people have good people around them
they shouldn't take them for granted at
all you know
but
you know i've had people ask me you know
how did i do it or you know you don't
hear about many
43 year old heroin addicts you know
enough
but without them i don't think i could
have shot you know
what advice can you give to families
that are dealing with
hardcore addicts like this
it's you just got to love them you know
it's uh
everybody wants to do that tough love
that you know
try to teach them a lesson there's no
lesson you're going to teach them that
you're not going to put them through
anything worse than they've already been
through you know
um
[Music]
you got to find it in your heart to care
about them enough to
to write it out and give them enough
opportunities to
to get it right you know
from the stories i've heard years and
years included it seems like it takes a
lot more patience than
99 of people have yeah
and that's it you know but that's you
know you could
i could say yeah i guess you could say
that about everything but it's
definitely true here you know
you just have to love them enough and be
patient enough to
you know
you never know that the next try they
may get it right you know
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in all of this
um
i would say
without a doubt i would say it's how
important love is you know
and what it can do and
how strong it can be you know
um
i don't know i
i think that's
we need a lot more of it in the world
you know
i had a lot of hate in my heart for a
long time and
you gotta let that go you know
once you let it go you know you can
go on
living a good life you know a better
life more productive life you know
and it's a day-to-day process but
it's you know it's worth doing
all right daniel thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you mark proud
of you
you